all right so flying at night is really
fun and in order to get your private
pilot you actually have to fly at night
you even have to do a short
cross-country flight at night so it's
really important for you to understand
the dimensions of flying at night and
it's something else to set personal
minimums about but overall I love flying
at night it's one of my favorite
favorite things to do and this is
actually a picture that the person
sitting on the right seat took when I
was landing in Bedford so what do you
see in this picture who can identify
where the runway is can at least see the
runway all right just just yes in the
yellow shirt this right after the yellow
cross and there's that's right so so the
Green Line is marking the threshold of
the runway along the sides of the runway
it's yellow and then becomes red at the
end what are those lights to the right
of the runway your glide slope what is
it called poppy all right come on guys
we've covered Fozzie's and poppies so
the the vazhi was the vertical one where
the two lights are on top and the two
lights are at the bottom and the poppy
is the horizontal one and so as you can
see in my beautiful picture because of
my perfect flying abilities I have two
red lights and two white lights thank
you very much yes
it either looks like I'm not level or
the person taking the picture isn't
level but it's definitely not level I
agree with you now I would tell you how
I'm getting bounced around by the wind
but in fact at night usually there isn't
that much wind so let's talk about the
definition of of night we actually had a
good conversation at dinner last night
with mark Nathanson and he was talking
about his FAA exam where he was
examining a friend of mine Emily on her
oral exam and asked her when sunset and
she said well which sunset do you meet
so there are a lot of different
definitions and so so if you're just
flying at night and you want to log
hours that you're flying at night then
it's really anytime after sunset or
after civil twilight but there are
specific requirements in terms of having
us you know landings at night and you
can log whether you're landing is at
night during or during the day and
they're a little bit more strict
restrictions so the landing has to be a
full hour after sunset and and if you're
in the wee hours of the morning then a
full hour before sunrise and that's
because that's because it's still pretty
light during that time so even after the
Sun sets
it stays bright for about an hour or so
and so they want to make sure that
you're really familiar with flying in
true night conditions yeah I love flying
at night and one thing that's a lot
easier is sometimes seeing the traffic
so seeing other aircraft if you get
notified you know hey there's a traffic
three o'clock you look out and there it
is you can see the light there also
aren't that many other planes so
sometimes you get the airport to
yourself or the tower controller to
yourself and the you know depending on
the the weather and the climate it can
be really great what's really
interesting is that in the US there's no
special rating so we talked about this
you don't you don't need your instrument
rating to fly at night now that's not
the case in other countries and I
wouldn't say that we're as I think
Phillips noted we don't think that the
the Mexicans know we think that maybe
they know something we don't which is
that you really need to take a lot of
precautions flying at night is in some
ways similar to flying in instrument
conditions and we talked about some of
the visual effects and cues that you can
get disoriented in it's so in your
during your private you're gonna have
three hours of night training which is
really cool so you're gonna fly at night
you're gonna also do a short
cross-country flight but in in terms of
currency requirements some people were
asking about currency requirements this
is one of the the currency requirements
that you really want to keep in mind so
this this lasts you know after you get
your pilot private pilot license in
order for you to fly with passengers you
have to have three takeoffs and landings
to a full stop within the the preceding
ninety days so this is important you
know if you go on a trip during the day
and if it's gonna be night you might
have to land somewhere kick out your
passengers do you hear deer currents the
human and then continue I've had to do
that at least once so night vision so we
talked a lot when we're talking about
human factors about your you know your
visual system so one thing I think
people might have heard of the different
rods and cones and your eyes so I'm
getting a lot of head nods so the the
rods are actually the thing that can
really help you see but but it's a lot
easier to look on the sides so looking
straight during the daytime that's where
you can see but your your rods that do a
better job at nighttime are your primary
receptors for night vision and so
unfortunately the problem is if you
stare right at something it might
actually be harder to see it than if you
were sort of scanning and you were five
to ten degrees off of what you were
looking at and so one thing when you're
flying at night when you're looking for
traffic instead of just looking in one
spot you know try to skin to to kind of
look around another thing is that it
takes you a long time for your eyes to
adjust to the darkness so you can just
probably have noticed this yourself you
know when you're in your room at night
or working
something you know your eyes take a
little time to adjust to that night
light and so what you want to do if
you're flying at night is to give
yourself a chance to adjust to that you
don't want to be in a very bright place
right before you go flying at night
because your eyes won't adjust another
thing you can consider doing is using
red lights and I actually do that so
this is a super fashionable picture of
me where's your giant headlamp and
actually have a red light headlight and
their pros and cons I think it's great
because it really helps you know you can
have illumination without it destroying
your your night vision adjustment but it
also washes out red color so you just
want to keep that in mind but also just
in general having that that lamp on your
head is really helpful although you look
not not so great it's a good thing that
even you know if you take off in the
evening when it's still bright outside
if you already have that light in place
and then once it gets dark once you need
it you have it right there again you're
not bending over moving your head a lot
and searching the ground or your bag to
look for a flashlight after it's dark
when you're trying to fly a plane that's
not a good thing if it's going to get
dark or could possibly get dark while
you're still flying have those
flashlights available make sure you know
that where the light light buttons are
for all of your all of your instrument
panels it's important to mention that
you know if the airplane is if
everything is working properly it should
have a dome light or a map reading light
or something that's in the airplane so
you don't absolutely need the flashlight
and unless something is broken
well you it depends you might need a
flashlight for example just to conduct
your pre-flight inspection so to walk
around the airplane make sure all the
control surfaces can move free and clear
you want to use a light to do that you
know I won't get into the details but
there was an accident Hanscom a couple
years back and one of the concerns was
that they had a lock on one of the
control surfaces and it was it was
nighttime when they were trying to take
off and so having a flashlight I think
is really critical in order to do your
pre-flight inspection to make sure your
airplane is safe to fly
yeah so there's a very good question do
you do anything special with your iPad
because it's enough to ruin your night
vision yeah so I actually think it is it
is definitely something I keep in mind
always you can adjust the brightness
setting on the iPad it still can be very
bright and then sometimes it has a night
mode and that does work for some things
it doesn't work for other things like I
think yeah the approach plates are still
pretty bright but you can make your
whole map and the weather information in
night mode and I think actually Garmin
default mode is a much better viewable
on your iPad than for flight as well yes
yes
yes as a suggestion when you're using a
tablet to invert the colors and that can
help make everything white that's black
would also be where the other colors
might change if you're looking for cues
like we talked earlier about the VFR
versus IFR lights make sure the green
didn't turn red and the red didn't turn
green okay so so night illusions so this
is something to keep in mind especially
in the Northeast there are so many
airports but also cities everywhere and
a lot of times if you you can
accidentally think that certain lights
or something else there's we talked
about the black hole illusion earlier
when we're talking about human factors
that if for example there's a lot of
snow around and it's dark it kind of
makes it even harder to see features on
the ground and if it makes it you might
actually be lower than you are than you
think you are just because if there
aren't any visual cues where you see
exactly where the ground is another
concern is if the runway lights are too
bright it can make it seem like the
runway is closer to you so that's why a
vazhi or papi some sort of glide slope
reference is a really good idea at night
to make sure your eyes aren't playing
tricks on you and you're actually where
you think you are so there's a whole
bunch of equipment rating so you need
this is you know you need everything
that you need during the day for VFR
flight but you also need some additional
lights and certainly if you want to
think about another issue is the
electrical system so that's a more
difficult thing that if you lose your
electrical system when you're flying at
night you know you don't have the
ability to kind of look outside to see
where you are quite as easily yeah and
if your airplane has circuit breakers
and doesn't have fuses and you don't
need the stairs spirits that have fuses
just so you aren't concerned and then
this is a reminder of all that equipment
that you need anyway during the day for
flying
so speaking more specifically about the
the lights that are required on an
aircraft so you actually have to have
lights related to navigation and so
they're different type of navigation
lights and generally have a red light on
the left they try to say
red is like port port is red the port
wine is red and so red is on the left
that's one way they suggest that you
remember that there's also this big
anti-collision strobe light that kind of
blinks some sometimes you actually have
to have that light all the time like
even during during the day to avoid
collisions but it's especially important
at night but you also it's also
especially important is when you turn it
off you don't want to keep that
anti-collision strobe light on when
you're taxing on the ground again when
you're flying sometimes it's hard to
tell if something is on the ground or if
it's in the air and if you see a bunch
of lights you might think it's a plane
that's that's flying and it can get
confusing so once you're off of an
active runway also turn off your
anti-collision strobe light this is
where it talks about that red light on
the on the left is kind of port but the
the basic idea is based on where these
are that if you see a red light that
it's probably an airplane and so if the
if the red light is on the left wing and
you see an airplane you it's usually if
I'm flying an airplane and this is
another airplane crossing me if it's
flying in this way I see the red light
if it's flying the other way then I see
the green light so the colors kind of
help you figure out which way the plane
is going I realize this slide is a
little confusing that flashing red is
not one of the navigation lights that
would be like navigate you know I can
anti-collision beacon or something
rotating yeah and we'll talk about
beacons next so one thing that's really
fun is when you're flying is to look for
airports so even if you're on a
commercial flight I really recommend
just stay staring out the window while
you're flying over a city and try to see
if you can see one of these beacons and
odds are you probably will even if
you're in a tall building and look out
the Northeast has so many airports you
might be able to find one of these
beacons so it'll basically be flashing
you know green white green white or if
it's a military airport slightly
different and so this little video if
you pay attention on the top right
corner it show
that green white green and the way that
I just said it where you see it and you
say what's happening that's a good way
to check with your copilot or just a
person sitting next to you if they're
seeing the same thing you are so there's
so many lights in a city and they're
different colors and they're same color
of street lights and other lights and so
to really make sure you've identified an
airport and the other person sitting
next to identified the same airport and
you both agree you're heading to the
same place it's good to make sure that
you guys that are following the beacon
and you're making sure you've identified
the same Airport that you're heading to
so this is just seems like people had a
lot of familiarity when we even just
started with the first picture of me
landing at Bedford so you can see all
the different lights on a runway the
types of lights that you see on the
runway depend on the runway itself so a
smaller Airport might only just have
lights kind of on the boundary of the
runway whereas you know really big long
runway or Boston Logan has a whole bunch
of lights going on the blue lights are
actually the taxiway lights and again so
if you're on a commercial flight you
really highly recommend getting a window
seat even if you have to pay 20 bucks
for it and while you're taxiing you know
look out the window and you'll see all
these blue lights while you're taxiing
and can look at the runway markers as
well yes
yes sometimes called those approach
light bars and those those are at big
big airports and even some runways even
have what's called like a is it a rabbit
or a ribbon where they have have lights
that a leaden light so it's not even
that they're all just kind of on but a
light that kind of turns so there's a
row of lights and they they they turn
them on in a row so it kind of looks
like a line that's pointing towards the
runway so even even here at Hanscom one
of the runways has that the one where
the ILS approach has that kind of I
think they called a ribbon or a rabbit
light that's a rabbit yeah so this is a
story I just wanted to share with you
recently I did a flight to Lawrence
Airport so Lawrence is very close by
it's just kind of north of here and I
was going to land at this Airport and I
know that from you know all the the
markings in the book that this runway
that I was landing at had a poppy but as
I was coming into Lynn so this is so if
you look in this so the run the runway
is up in the left corner of this picture
over here and so that's that's what the
runway looked like you know this is the
picture as you can see on the left and
the right there is no poppy so there's
no poppy there and so as I was coming in
to land you know I wanted to make sure I
was in the right place everything was
working properly so I asked the tower
controller it was a towered Airport you
know is the is the poppy on is it active
as it broken is there something I missed
in the note am that the poppy was out
and he said that the poppy was on and so
this confused me because obviously the
poppy is not on and so I I didn't know
exactly if you know something was wrong
either either it was out or maybe it was
at the wrong runway I didn't want to
take any chances so I executed it go
around and I told the tower controller
you know I don't see the poppy he was
like no the poppy is definitely on so I
you know
okay I didn't I go around I proceeded in
the traffic pattern I came back and
miraculously the second time around I
could see the poppy very clearly tower
controller stuck to his story that it
was on the whole time but I have photo
evidence that that wasn't true so here
on the left you can see the poppy I
think the reason that story is relevant
also though is that you you want to make
sure that you are seeing what you expect
to see right we talked about the
importance of a poppy certainly to help
with with issues in terms of what your
height is and visual illusions that are
going on but also if you expect
something to be there and it's not you
know maybe there's a lighted window and
the lighted winds up snot there you
might want to you know check that I miss
a notification of it being out or made
in the right place you don't want to
proceed especially at night into an area
that you might not be familiar with it
also obviously helps to have a tower
controller to talk to if you're an
uncontrolled Airport there is something
called pilot controlled lighting that
we'll get into
so this is just talking more about run
with lights at big runways ok pilot
controlled lighting so you'll see in
this this little video so it starts off
there's there's no light at the runway
and then all of a sudden the the light
props up so we're looking right over
here and that one has that ribbon light
or rabbit light that I was talking about
so you see the white light that's moving
and then it lights up the whole thing
so pilot controlled lighting is kind of
cool so at non-towered airports or even
at airports that are usually towered but
at night they might not have the tower
controller working overnight they can
turn off the lights and the way that you
turn it on is you actually do pilot
controlled lighting so there's a
frequency sometimes it's the same
frequency as the tower frequency and you
basically on the same button that you
hold down when you're speaking you just
click it so you keep pushing that button
so if you push it five times you know it
turns on the lights the number of times
you click it impacts what the brightness
is of the intensity of the light one
thing to also keep in mind is that the
light is usually only on for about 15
minutes so if you're still very far away
from the airport it's not a good idea to
turn the turn the light on because you
don't want a situation where it takes
you 15 minutes to get there and then as
soon as your landing lights turn off so
it's good to just kind of wait so you're
actually close to the airport and do
that now one thing that maybe isn't
recommended but it's really fun to do
one time I was flying at night and I was
flying over a bunch of unpowered
airports or a whole bunch in the
Northeast area and just to get used to
pilot controlled lighting we would kind
of look up on towered airports we were
flying over it would just light up
various airports it was really fun but
it's generally a bad idea again because
if somebody is coming in to land and the
lights are already on they might you
know turn off when they're not supposed
to so you really want you want the pilot
who's landing to control when it turns
on so they get their 15 minutes
so I just wanted to have it yes go ahead
question is are the poppy and vazhi
lights always on either the left or on
the right of the runway and no I think
I've seen both situations I think left
is kind of standard but for whatever
reason you also may see him on the right
yeah I think they were on the left here
in this Lawrence picture at what point
in the approach you typically want to
see the light so at what point in the
approach do you want to see the lights
well usually before you're making your
your approach you see the lights so when
you're identifying the airport as is
when you see the lights so we didn't
talk about it much today but how you
usually do a landing we discussed a
little bit on instrument approaches but
when you're just flying VFR including
VFR at night the way that you do an
approach to landing actually involves
flying let me let me draw it over here
and while you're doing that I'll I'll
point out that the runway lights are
their directional so they'll be
substantial if you're lined up with the
runway they'll be a lot brighter still
not as bright as the surrounding clutter
and the shopping malls and so forth but
there'll be much much brighter when
you're lined up with the runway then if
you're looking from straight down or
from the downwind leg as Tina is about
to drop for you so if this is your your
runway and so it would have all of its
runway marking so let's say this is
runway 2 9
you don't just kind of you could do a
straight in where you just kind of come
to it but most of the time you would
practice doing an approach where you
actually enter the traffic pattern 45
degrees so at a 45 degree angle here
and then you enter this is a kind of the
midpoint so you enter in at the 45
degrees and then you continue this way
and so that's considered being on the
downwind leg so why would it be
considered being on the downwind leg
anyone very good so the wind is going to
be blowing this way because when you
land you want to land into the wind and
so if you're flying in the opposite
direction of the runway the winds gonna
be behind you so you're on the downwind
leg this point over here is called being
a beam the runway or a beam the numbers
and then you fly out about to here
usually you'll start getting used to
what this angle is it might also be 45
degrees but sometimes it depends on if
there are kind of noise abatement areas
and you're supposed to make a close
approach or a different approach but
essentially you come out over here you
can see the the runway out your wing and
then you turn your base leg so that's
this way it's and then you're on base
pretty much depending on the airplane
when your a beam the numbers you might
start getting into runway in your
landing configuration you might start
you know putting ten degrees of flaps
slowing down your airspeed you might
want to be you know 80 or 90 knots of
airspeed then you turn base you might
want to put in another ten degrees of
flaps you're at twenty degrees of flaps
and then as you come in you might want
to be between 80 and 90 knots and now
when you turn final that's final and as
you get much closer it's short final and
here you want to be trying to be very
aligned with the numbers and the runway
at the beginning you want to be looking
at the vazhi and poppy but once you get
closer again you want to look at the
runway itself so the question was when
do you want to see the lights of the
runway before you enter the traffic
pattern you want to see that because
otherwise you don't know
Polly where the midpoint is you don't
know how to enter you don't know how to
make sure you're exactly flying
alongside the runway
yeah and just keep in mind this is uh
this is called right traffic because
you're making right turns at a towered
Airport like Hanscom depending on what
direction you're coming from you'll be
assigned either right or left traffic to
keep you from crossing the runway at an
unpowered Airport it's conventional
usually to fly left traffic pattern
unless there's terrain or some other
consideration that'll be published and
they'll tell you that right the right
pattern is preferred but if they don't
tell you anything and left traffic is
the convention yeah absolutely and just
for completeness once you take off
you're in the upwind and then you could
turn crosswind and then downwind again
and there might be other people that are
flying the other side of the traffic
pattern at the same time so that's
that's usually the case at Hanscom
they're people doing both sort of
question yes
oh yeah so so the question was do you
have to call an airport to tell them to
turn on the lights so Hyannis in the
story I was giving before had the lights
on but as we talked about procession
your heading indicator in this
particular plane was really really not
good and you have to regardless you have
to keep updating your heading indicator
with your magnetic compass during flight
so your heading indicator is going to
drift and you know get a couple degrees
off and so throughout the flight you
have to continuously look at your
magnetic compass and adjust your heading
indicator and so usually it you only
have to do that you know every so often
maybe every thirty minutes every hour
but this particular plane that was in
it's just it was just a terrible
instrument and it would get you know 20
degrees off within five minutes and I
had to it was basically just moving it
all the time that the thing was
basically busted and the problem with
with it was I was flying at night and at
nighttime although you can illuminate
your flight instruments you can't
illuminate that magnetic compass and so
that little ball with the liquid in it I
couldn't I couldn't illuminate it
without having my headlight on and then
losing my night vision so it was very
difficult for me to figure out exactly
what heading I was on at that particular
moment and so that's why I wanted to
call it PI anise which had two
intersecting runways to just double
check and double confirm I was going
into the runway that I thought I was
going into and the really nice tower
controller at Hyannis lit up to a higher
light intensity the runway that I was
gonna land on so I could make sure yes
that's where I was going and then he
reduced the light intensity back down I
was a great commercial for a glass
cockpit or an HSI which is slave to a
magnetometer out in the wing all right
yeah we should wrap this one up
so the last thing is just I wanted to do
a little bit of a discussion on where
you might try to land if you had an
engine failure and you weren't able to
get your engine restarted most of the
time if you have an engineering failure
there's a whole flow that you go through
and turn that you probably mess
something up you didn't have enough make
or whatever it was and you can get the
engine restarted but if you can't get
the engine restarted and you have to do
a forced landing where would you go
so in this picture the red X is where
I'm saying you had that failure you
don't think you could make it all the
way to Mansfield or another airport so I
threw up a couple letters but we're you
know let's talk about the thought
process how would you decide where you
would land land in the Hudson okay one
suggestion great ha a RC because they
are populated areas very good you would
get that right on the FAA exam all right
what about Bravo yeah Bravo
why why would you choose Bravo why is
the road a good place to land at night
as future water D is not on Delta is not
on water that blue line is a mode B
transponder line illumination that's it
a road is likely to be illuminated so
you can actually see it at night and
it'll be this nice long runway that you
can you can land on yes it's Hey
yeah absolutely it's much better to pick
a paved surface and landing in a dark
field which might turn out to be a lake
and you didn't realize also D if you
notice is towards the mountains
so landing in the mountains it's not a
good plan trying to see mountains and at
night it's not a good plan it's probably
not a good idea to go north in this
picture all right that was the airspace
it's part of the Boston Bravo yeah
that's the blue line surrounding the
Boston class Bravo air and then that
magenta one down there the bottle at the
bottom is the 30 nautical mile mode sea
veil it's called and then these here
that's a that's one tower and these M
things that's multiple radio towers
what's really interesting is actually
the speed at which you land so this is
true for day or night operations when a
cessna is is landing it usually lands at
about 40 to 50 knots and turns out
that's actually very similar to kind of
the miles per hour at which a car would
be traveling on a highway so it's really
cool is if you did have to land on a
highway you'd probably be going about
the same speed as the cars yeah you
could you've been on busy highways
people seem to have just walked away you
never hear about somebody Atlanta on the
highway and then was killed by a car all
right what's last point on that is it in
Alaska you're actually required to do a
landing on a highway because they have
so few airports in a couple places
all right let's we got one more
presentation than the four-fight guys so
we'll wrap this with my final advice
based on I've done a fair amount of
night flying it's good to take off
before civil twilight and that gives you
time to adjust to the world of darkness
so I like to take off when it's still a
little bit light and I my landing in the
dark especially at a familiar Airport I
treat all the non local night flights as
instrument flights the FAA says you can
fly at night that doesn't mean that you
should do every flight at night
especially without a co-pilot so either
bring a co-pilot or use an IFR approach
that helps you to find the correct
way at the correct airport remember
you're to pilot airline crews have quite
a few times landed at the wrong Airport
altogether bigger airports are better at
night you know landing at Hanscom at
night is a lot like during the day
there's just a million lights and that's
a nice big space and then the serious
parachutes good at night
you